pensemos ahora en expresiones con más de
una variable y para ello vamos a
escribir por ejemplo una muy sencilla
que tal a más b
cuánto será cuando am tiene un valor de
7 y ve tiene un valor de 2 esto es muy
sencillo de hecho lo que vamos a hacer
es sustituir cada vez que veamos una por
el valor que tenemos y cada vez que
veamos una vez por el valor que tengo
que tenemos en este caso a es igual a 7
así es que escribiremos
vale 7 + b b en este caso tiene valor de
más vez será igual a y esto es muy
sencillo ya un 7 más 2 sabemos
perfectamente que es igual a 9 está muy
sencillo verdad vamos a hacer una un
poco más complicada que les parece
cuánto serán x por qué
- y más seamos más más 3 x 3 por x
recuerda que aquí esta variable que es
el 3 está multiplicando a x y nosotros
vamos a evaluar esta expresión cuando x
tenga un valor de 3
y yo
tenga un valor de 2
vamos entonces a reescribir sustituyendo
las x por el valor 3 que estamos
considerando en este caso y las 10 por
el valor del número 2 vamos a reescribir
esto aquí abajo con un poco más de
espacio y tendremos entonces que x
que está multiplicando allí
que ahora vale 2
le restaremos
dos de iu y una vez más sumaremos
3 que está multiplicando a x x que tiene
valor de 3 podemos entonces hacer
nuestras multiplicaciones para
simplificar esto tenemos que 3 por 2 es
igual a 6 3 por 3 es igual a 9
y colocaremos este 2 que aquí está
restando 2
tendremos entonces que 6 menos 2 es
igual a 49 es igual a 13 en este caso
nuestra respuesta será 13 justo cuando x
tenga valor de 3 y que tenga valor de 2